let's say I have a line that goes
through the origin I'll draw it in r2
but this can be extended to an arbitrary
RN we draw my axes
those are my axes right they're not
perfectly drawn but I think you get the
idea let me draw a line that goes
through the origin here so that is my
line there and we know that a line in
any RN we're doing it in r2 can be
defined as just all of the possible
scalar multiples of some vector so let's
say that this is my some vector right
here that's on the line we can define
our line we could say L is equal to the
set of all the scalar multiples let me
say that this is vector let's say that
that is V right there so it's all the
possible scalar multiples of our vector
V where the scalar multiples by
definition or they're just any real
they're just any real number so
obviously if you can if you take all of
the possible multiples of be both
positive multiples and negative
multiples and less than one multiples
fraction multiples you will define
you'll have a set of vectors that will
essentially define or I can specify
every point on that line that goes
through the origin and we know of course
this wasn't a line that went through the
origin you would have to shift it by
some vector would have to be some other
vector plus CV but anyway we're starting
off with this line definition that goes
through the origin what I want to do in
this video is to define the idea of a
projection of a projection onto L of
some other vector X of some other vector
so let me draw my some other vector X
let's say that this right here is my
other vector X now a projection I'm
going to give you just a sense of it and
then we'll define a little bit more
precisely a projection I always imagined
if you had some light source that were
perpendicular somehow orthogonal to our
line so let's say our light source the
light was shining down like this because
and I'm doing that direction because
that is perpendicular to my line I
imagine the projection of X onto this
line is kind of the shadow of X so if I
were if this light was coming down I
would just draw a perpendicular like
that and the shot
of X onto L would be that vector right
there so we can kind of view it as the
shadow shadow of X on our line L that's
one way to think of it another way to
think of it in you can think of it
however you like is how much of X goes
in the L directions o and but the the
technique would be the same you draw
perpendicular from X to L and you say
okay then what do i how much of L have
to go in that direction
to get to my perpendicular either of
those are how I think of the idea of a
projection I think the shadow is part of
the motivation for why you it's even
called a projection right when you
project something you're kind of beaming
light and seeing where the light hits on
a wall and you're kind of doing that
here you're beaming light and you're
seeing where that light hits on a line
in this case but this isn't a you can't
do anything with this definition this is
just kind of an intuitive sense of what
a projection is so we need to figure out
some way to calculate this or a more
mathematically precise definition and
one thing we can do is when I created
this projection let me actually draw
another projection of another line so or
another vector just you get the idea if
I had some other vector over here that
look like that the projection of this
onto the line would look something like
this you just draw a perpendicular and
this projection would be like that so I
don't want to dot for just this case I
want to give you the sensitive script
the shadow of any vector onto this line
so how can we think about it with our
original example well every case no
matter how I perceive it I drew I
dropped a perpendicular down here and so
if we can be constructive vector right
here we could say hey that vector is
always going to be perpendicular to the
line and we can do that I would have
been talking about it if we couldn't so
let me define this vector which I'm not
even define it what is this vector going
to be if this vector let me not use all
these misses let me say that this vector
we know we want to somehow get to this
blue vector let me yeah let me keep it
in blue that blue vector is the
projection of X onto L that's what we
want to get to now one thing we can look
at is this pink vector right there what
is that pink vector that pink vector
that
true this is this is X that's the vector
X minus the projection minus this blue
vector over here minus the projection of
X onto L right if you add the projection
to the pink vector you get X so if you
add this blue projection of X to X minus
the projection of extra or it's going to
get X we also know that this pink vector
is orthogonal to the line itself which
means it's orthogonal to every vector on
the line which also means that this dot
product is going to be 0 so let me let
me define the projection this way the
projection this is going to be my
slightly more mathematical definition
the projection of onto L of some vector
X is going to be some vector some vector
that's in in L right I drew it right
here this blue vector I'll trace it with
white right here some vector in L where
where and this might be a little bit
unintuitive where X minus where X minus
the projection vector X minus the
projection onto L of X is orthogonal is
orthogonal to my line so I'm saying the
projection this is my definition I'm
defining the projection of X onto L to
some vector in L where X minus that
projection is orthogonal to L this is my
definition that is a little bit more
precise and I think you makes it makes a
bit of sense why it connects to the idea
of n of the shadow or a projection but
how can we deal with this I mean this is
still just in words how can actually
calculate the projection of X onto L
well the key clue here is this notion
that X minus the projection of X is
orthogonal to L so let's see if we can
use that somehow so the first thing we
need to realize is by definition because
the projection of X onto L is some
vector in L that means that some scalar
multiple of V some scalar multiple of
our defining vector of our V right there
so we could also say we could say hey
look we could rewrite our projection
ah of X onto L we could write it as some
scalar multiple times our vector V right
we can say that this is equivalent to
our projection now we also know that X
minus our projection is orthogonal to L
so we also know that X minus our
projection and I could I just said that
I could rewrite my projection is some
multiple of this vector right there you
can see it the way I drew it read it's
almost looks like it's two times this
vector so we know that X minus our
projection this is our projection right
here it is orthogonal to L orthogonal ax
T by definition means it's dot product
with any vector in L is 0 so let's dot
it with some vector and L well we could
dot it with we can dot it with this
vector V that's what we used to define
now so let's dot it with V and we know
that that must be equal to 0 we're
taking this vector right here dotting it
with V and we know that this has to be
equal to 0 that has to be equal to 0 so
let's use our properties of dot products
to see if we can calculate a particular
value of C because once we know a
particular value of C then we can just
always multiply that times about the
vector V which we are given and we will
have our projection and then I'll show
it to you with some actual numbers so
let's see if we can calculate a C so if
we distribute the C or sorry if we
distribute the V we know the dot product
exhibits the distributive property this
expression can be rewritten as as X dot
V right X dot V minus C times V dot V C
times V dot V I rearranged things we
know that the scalar we know that C
minus C V dot V is the same thing we
could write it as minus C V so minus C
times V dot V and all of this of course
is equal to 0 and then if we want to
solve for C let's add C V dot V to both
sides of the equation and you get X dot
V is equal to C times V dot V solving
for C let's divide both sides of this
equation by V dot V you get there in a
different color C is equal to
this X dot V divided by V dot V now what
we'll see see was we sang the projection
of X let me write it here the projection
of X onto L is equal to some scalar
multiple right we know it's in the line
we know it's in the line so it's some
scalar multiple of this defining vector
some scalar multiple of the vector V and
we just figured out what that with that
scalar multiple is going to be it's
going to be it is going to be X dot V
over V dot V and this of course is just
going to be a number right this is a
scalar still even though we have all
these vectors here when you take their
dot products you just end up with the
number and you multiply that number
times V you just kind of scale V and you
get your projection so in this case the
way I drew it up here my dot product
should end up with some scaling factor
that's you know maybe close to two so
that if I taste art with a V and I scale
it up by two this value would be two and
I'd get a projection that looks
something like that now this is looks a
little abstract to you so let's do it
with some real vectors and I think it'll
make a little bit more sense and nothing
I did here only applies to r2 everything
I did here can be extended to an
arbitrarily high def dimension so even
though we're doing an r2 and r2 and r3
is where we tend to deal with
projections the most this could apply to
RN let me do it this particular case let
me define L let's let me define my line
L to be the set of all scalar multiples
of the vector I don't know let's say the
vector to one such that all of them are
you know any the C is any real number so
let me draw my let me draw my axes here
that's my vertical axis this is my
horizontal axis right there and so my
line is all the scalar multiples of the
vector 2.1 and actually let me just call
my vector 2.1 let me call that right
there the vector V let me draw that so I
go 1 2 go up 1 that right there is my
vector V
vector V right there and the line is all
of the possible scalar multiples of that
so let me draw that so all the possible
scalar multiples of that you just keep
going in that direction or you keep
going backwards in that direction or
anything in between that's what my line
is if we just all of the scalar
multiples of my vector V my vector of my
vector V now let's say I have another
vector X let's say I have a vector X now
let's say that X is equal to 2/3
let me draw X X is 2 and then you go 1 2
3 so X will look like this vector X will
look like that now let me draw a little
bit better than that
vector X will look like that that is
vector X what we want to do is figure
out the projection of X onto L we can
use this definition right here so let me
write it down the projection of X onto L
is equal to what it's equal to X dot V
right where V is kind of the defining
vector for our line so it's equal to X
which is 2 3 dot V which is 2 1 2 1 all
of that over V dot V so all of that over
2 1 dot 2 1 times our original defining
vector V so what's our original defining
vector it's this one right here 2 1 so
times the vector 2 1 and what is this
equal see when you take 2 when you take
these two dot at each other you have 2
times 2 plus 3 times 1 so 4 plus 3 so
you get 7 this all simplified to 7 and
then this you get 2 times 2 plus 1 times
1 so 4 plus 1 is 5 so you get 7 v that
all simplified to 5 that was a very fast
simplification you might have been
daunted by this kind of strange-looking
expression but we take dot products they
actually tend to simplify quite very
quickly and then you just multiply
at times your defining vector for the
line so we're scaling it up by a factor
by a factor of seven fifths so multiply
it times the vector 2 1 and what do you
get you get the vector we do it a new
color you get the vector 14 over 5 and
the vector 7 over 5 and just so we can
visualize this or plot a little better
let me write it as decimals 14 over 5 is
2 and 4/5 which is 2.8 and this is 1 and
2/5 which is 1.4 and so the projection
of X onto L is 2.8 1.4 so let's see 1 2
2.8 is right about there and I go 1
point 4 is right about there so the
vector is going to be right about there
I haven't even drawn this to precisely
but you get the idea this is the
projection our computation shows us that
this is the projection of X onto L and
if we draw a perpendicular right there
we see that it's consistent with our
idea of this being the shadow of X onto
our line L well now now we actually can
calculate projections in the next video
I'll actually show you how to figure out
a matrix representation for this what's
essentially a transformation